Les derniers jours, j'ai été invité à partager une dévotion sur les thèmes de la relation entre la gloire des dieux seul et une vie vécue pour la gloire des dieux seul.
Et aujourd'hui, on va se plonger davantage dans cette thématique.
Car comme vous le savez, l'un des solas de la réforme protestante, c'est cette dévise composée de cinq éléments.
Quand on pense à Solideo Gloria, nous pensons à cette bataille pour la liberté du culte, cette bataille contre toute l'idolâtrie pratiquée dans les contextes de l'Église catholique.
Et donc, c'était avant tout une bataille pour nettoyer l'environnement du culte.
Mais ce n'était pas que ça.
Car l'objectif n'était pas tout simplement de nettoyer visiblement toute l'idolâtrie qui marquait l'Église catholique de l'époque.
Mais c'était surtout l'intérêt de pouvoir réjouir et contempler les vrais dieux.
De pouvoir adorer librement Dieu.
Devant la période de la réforme protestante, la contre-réforme a cherché à supprimer en interdissant les protestants de célébrer publiquement leur culte.
Et il devrait même, surtout en France, se conformer, même s'ils pouvaient être tolérés de temps en temps, à vivre leur vie ou leur foi de manière privée.
Et ils devraient participer publiquement à la messe et d'autres pratiques idolâtres d'adoration de l'Église catholique romaine.
Mais ce qui va ressortir le plus, et ce qui est notre intérêt ici aujourd'hui,
ce n'est pas tout simplement de considérer comment l'Église réformée a réussi à tourner les visages de tous les idoles envers la gloire de Dieu.
Mais comment en fait la contemplation de Dieu a conduit ces personnes à vivre une vie radicalement pour la gloire de Dieu.
J'ai ressenti un peu de résonance là, si c'est possible.
Et donc c'est important, quand on pense à solider au Gloria, seulement la gloire de Dieu,
nous pensons avant tout à créditer seulement à Dieu tous les mérites de notre salut.
Les saluts de l'être humain ne peuvent avoir lieu par aucun autre mérite, qui est l'œuvre de Dieu seul.
C'est Dieu qui a tous les mérites pour notre salut, et donc c'est Dieu les seuls êtres dignes de notre adoration.
Et c'était les deux problématiques principales de l'Église catholique,
c'est de suggérer aux personnes que même d'exercer leur foi envers Christ pourrait être considérée comme une bonne œuvre.
Et que toutes les bonnes œuvres pourraient contribuer à leur salut, ou à la maintenance au monde de leur salut.
Mais c'est intéressant de remarquer que la problématique n'était pas qu'à participer au nom de notre salut,
mais c'était aussi la réalité de créditer à des hommes une gloire qui est exclusive à Dieu.
Et donc on a élevé l'image des papes, du haut clergé, des saints et des icônes.
Et donc, solide et gloria, c'est principalement un retour à l'adoration des dieux seuls.
Mais c'est intéressant, comme je vous ai dit, de voir quelle est la relation
de pouvoir revenir à adorer les seuls vrais dieux.
Et à partir de là, mener une vie pour la gloire des dieux seuls.
Vivre seulement pour la gloire des dieux.
Et donc, nous allons considérer quelques vérités basées sur ces textes.
Je pense que ces textes nous montrent de manière très claire ces mouvements.
Donc là, verset 32,
C'est l'apôtre Paul qui, pendant onze chapitres jusque-là,
est en train de traiter une doctrine afin de corriger une mauvaise compréhension des dieux
et de la manière dont Dieu sauve l'humanité.
Donc, attention à la relation entre, avant tout, nos mauvaises conceptions des dieux,
nos mauvaises conceptions du salut,
la correction de nos mauvaises conceptions par la doctrine,
et peut-être les plus importants, la relation entre doctrine et adoration.
Ici, Paul, il va exploser en doxologie à partir de toute la théologie qu'il est en train de défendre.
Car au moment où il considère qu'en tant que juif,
il n'avait aucune importance supérieure aux autres nations païennes,
il déclare ouvertement, Dieu a tous renfermé dans la désobéissance,
afin d'utiliser des miséricordes envers tous.
Et là, il ne peut pas s'empêcher d'éloigner Dieu.
La théologie morte ne sauve personne.
La vraie théologie, elle doit toujours déclencher l'adoration.
Et donc ici, il dit,
« Oh, profondeur des richesses ».
Plusieurs personnes considèrent ces passages comme une digression.
Il était là, très organisé, comme un grand théologien.
On imagine que Paul serait un académique.
Mais là, il fait la théologie au milieu des missions.
Et pour plus organiser qu'il soit sa théologie,
à plusieurs reprises, il va laisser tout cet ordre littéraire
pour manifester son adoration.
Il a dit, « Oh, profondeur des richesses,
de la sagesse et de la science des dieux,
que ses jugements sont insondables et ses voies incompréhensibles,
car qui a connu la pensée du Seigneur
ou qui a été son conseiller ?
Qui lui a donné les premiers pour avoir,
pour qu'il ait à recevoir un retour ? »
Et les versets 36,
« C'est de lui, par lui et pour lui qui sont toutes choses.
Toutes choses existent.
De lui, par lui, pour lui.
Et donc, à lui, la gloire dans tous les siècles.
Amen. »
Vous voyez ?
Et il sort d'une contemplation doctrinaire
qui purifie la vision de vrai Dieu
et il ne peut pas, il ne peut s'empêcher
de déborder en adoration.
Et donc, le mouvement, il est clair.
Et ce qui va suivre, quand on arrive au chapitre 12,
« Je vous exhorte donc, frères,
par la décompression des dieux,
à offrir vos corps comme un sacrifice vivant,
sans agréable à Dieu. »
Donc, quelle est la relation qu'on est intéressé à avoir dans ces passages ?
C'est nettoyer notre vision corrompue des dieux,
c'est-à-dire idolâtrie,
car toute conception des dieux,
qui n'est pas celle que Dieu a révélée par sa parole,
est idolâtrie.
Donc, on va sortir du cadre idolâtre.
On va contempler les vrais dieux et les vrais évangiles.
Et c'est impossible, inévitable,
qu'en ayant contemplé les vrais dieux,
on soit en train de déborder d'adoration
et que cette adoration nous conduise à mener une vie pour sa gloire.
« Je vous exhorte, par les compassions de Dieu,
à offrir vos corps comme un sacrifice vivant,
sans agréable à Dieu,
ce qui sera de votre part un culte raisonnable. »
Vous voyez la logique ?
Contemplez la gloire de Dieu,
vivez pour la gloire de Dieu.
C'est impossible de vivre par la gloire de Dieu
si nous ne les contemplons pas,
nous ne réjouissons pas de la gloire de Dieu.
Donc, lorsque nous voyons les vies des hommes,
des saints au long de l'histoire
qui ont manifesté une vie très belle,
un témoignage très puissant,
ce que nous sommes en train de voir comme fondation de leur vie,
c'est leur vision de Dieu,
une vision grande de Dieu,
une vision glorieuse de Dieu.
Et nous allons donc considérer
quatre vérités liées à cette relation
entre contempler la gloire de Dieu
et vivre pour la gloire de Dieu.
La première, c'est les fondements.
La gloire de Dieu est la fondation
ou les fondements d'une vie vécue pour sa gloire.
C'est important de remarquer ici
que les versets,
la fin du verset 36,
« à lui soit la gloire pour toujours »,
elle doit être comprise comme une exhortation,
un commandement, si vous voulez, envers nous.
Nous devons vivre pour la gloire de Dieu.
Mais avant de voir par cette perspective,
nous devons considérer
que l'apôtre Paul ici,
il est en train de faire un constat.
Il est en train de parler de l'existence,
de l'histoire,
du gouvernement de Dieu
indépendamment de nos perceptions,
de nos opinions à propos de la vie.
Car ces mises en question
par rapport à la gloire de Dieu,
nous les faisons aussi
à cause de notre petitesse
et de notre corruption.
car qui a connu la pensée du Seigneur
pour être son conseiller
à combien de reprises
notre manque de plaisir en Dieu,
de contentement dans la vie,
mais vient des mises en question
de la bonté des dieux envers nous
ou de la puissance des dieux
car nos vies ne vont pas
dans la direction
où on imaginerait
que ça serait le mieux pour nous.
Comment Dieu est peut-être
en train de glorifier son nom
dans ma vie aujourd'hui
si les choses vont si mal
comme j'ai l'impression d'aller ?
Et si Paul est en train de dire
plus ou moins quelque chose comme ça,
peu importe votre perception des choses,
tout existe dès lui,
par lui et pour lui.
Ce qu'il est en train de dire
quand il dit à lui,
ça a la gloire pour toujours,
c'est vous pouvez avoir
l'incapacité de regarder les choses
de manière à voir
la gloire de Dieu s'est manifestée
mais ça ne va changer
dans aucun centimètre
le fait que Dieu est en train
de provoquer, de produire,
de manifester sa gloire
par toutes les choses
qui sont en train de se passer.
Même les pièces les plus moches
de ces mosaïques à l'histoire,
quand on les regarde des proches,
sont en train de contribuer
à la manifestation de sa gloire.
La mort du Christ à la croix
étant la pièce la plus moche.
Et en même temps,
étant celle qui va révéler
de manière la plus suprême
la gloire de Dieu.
Et donc, avant tout,
c'est un constat,
c'est une déclaration.
Toutes les choses sont
de lui,
par lui et pour lui,
à lui soit la gloire
pour toujours.
Et donc la réalité,
c'est que la fondation
pour une existence
ou notre existence
ou nos vies
pour la gloire de Dieu,
c'est la gloire
de Dieu lui-même.
Ça, comme Calvin
mettait beaucoup d'emphase,
c'est quelque chose
de logique.
Ce qui est mis en emphase
dans ces passages,
c'est surtout la sagesse
de Dieu dans la gouvernance
des choses
en tant que créateur
et en tant que celui
qui est en train
de soutenir toutes les choses.
Et là, Calvin,
il va dire
si Dieu est créateur
et c'est lui
qui soutient toutes les choses,
toutes les choses
sont sa possession
et dépendent de lui
pour exister.
Donc, c'est une prérogative
complètement juste
et logique
de la part de Dieu
d'exiger de ses créatures
une vie pour sa gloire.
Donc, la première chose
qu'on doit s'empêcher
lorsqu'on considère
une vie pour la gloire de Dieu,
c'est de mettre en question
les commandements
des vies pour sa gloire.
C'est une vie d'obéissance,
de soumission,
sachant que Dieu
a la prérogative
de demander de nous
une vie vécue
pour sa gloire.
Mais ce n'est pas
qu'il y ait tout simplement
à juste titre
que Dieu exige
qu'on vive pour sa gloire,
c'est aussi
la nature inévitable
de toutes les choses.
C'est intéressant
de remarquer
que lorsque
les mystères
de la gouvernance
de Dieu
sont en train
de se révéler
au fur et à mesure,
nous sommes
progressivement
et plus explicitement
devant la manifestation
de la gloire de Dieu.
Et donc,
quand est-ce qu'on va mettre
en question
la gloire des dieux
dans l'existence ?
Ce sont des thèmes
qui nous touchent
plus directement
tant qu'être humain,
liés au péché,
liés au salut.
Ce sont nos crises
à cet égard.
Et la réalité,
c'est qu'ici,
l'apôtre Paul
est en train
de présenter
à partir
de l'avouement
de Jésus-Christ,
les mystères
qui sont révélés,
même si on a eu
l'impression
pour les juifs
que tout leur
légalisme,
qui toute leur
transpiration,
performance
pour se sauver
ne servait de rien.
Et l'impression
que tous ces païens-là
qui menaient
une vie de débauche
et qui sont en train
de se convertir,
il y a des crises
dans nos mentalités
basées sur performance.
Et c'est intéressant
de remarquer,
il est en train
de manifester
comment les Christ,
il est suffisant
pour manifester
la gloire des dieux
dans la gouvernance
de l'histoire.
Mais c'est intéressant
car il est en train
de parler de la création,
il est en train
de parler de la gouvernance,
de la providence.
Et donc,
c'est intéressant
de remarquer en fait
que c'est impossible,
attention,
que les choses
ne glorifient pas Dieu
dans un univers
qui a été créé
par un Dieu glorieux.
Et là,
c'est l'emphase
de Calvin
quand il a parlé
que l'univers
tout entier
est le théâtre
de la gloire des dieux.
Donc,
quand on pense
tout simplement
à l'univers
qui dit
« Amen »
à la volonté des dieux
par nature,
c'est-à-dire
tout l'univers
qui est en train
de nous entourer,
l'univers qui n'est pas
personnel,
si on peut dire
comme ça,
tous ceux
qui par nature
glorifient Dieu
glorifient Dieu.
Pourquoi ?
Car Dieu
est son auteur.
C'est Dieu
qui est en train
de créer
toutes les choses.
Donc,
pour donner un exemple
à mes enfants,
je présente toujours
l'arbre.
Je dis
« Regardez
comment derrière l'arbre
il y a
l'intelligence des dieux,
il y a la beauté
des dieux
car il l'a adorné
avec des fleurs,
mais il y a aussi
la bonté des dieux
car une sémence
se transforme en arbre.
Cet arbre
devient bel
mais elle produit
aussi des fruits.
L'intelligence,
la beauté,
la bonté des dieux,
toutes les molécules
de l'univers
sont en train
de pointer
envers la gloire
des dieux
et sont en train
de dire
« Amen »
à la volonté
des dieux
par nature.
Tout ce qui nous entoure
pointe envers
la gloire des dieux
et par une raison
des corruptions,
de sortir
de la normalité,
les êtres humains
qui étaient censés
être ceux
qui manifesteraient
davantage
la gloire des dieux
dans une dimension
plus élevée,
celle de la moralité,
celle de la personnalité.
Nous sommes les seuls
qui vont se révéler
contre la nature
pour notre propre mal.
Une autodestruction.
Et par nature
toutes les choses
glorifient Dieu.
Et donc par défaut
toutes les choses
inévitablement
vont glorifier Dieu
car Dieu n'est pas
tout simplement
en train de créer
les choses
comme un Dieu glorieux.
Il est celui
qui est en train
de gouverner
toutes les choses
afin que même
nos actions mauvaises
convergent à sa gloire.
Mais nous pouvons dire
non seulement
par nature
l'univers des dieux
glorifie Dieu
car c'est les dieux
glorieux
qui l'a créé.
C'est juste
que Dieu exige
qu'on vit pour sa gloire
car c'est lui
qui nous a créés
et qui nous soutient.
Mais nous devons dire
avant tout
et surtout
heureusement
la gloire des dieux
elle est fondément
de notre vie
pour sa gloire.
Pourquoi ?
Car ce que Dieu
est en train
de révéler
dans la création
à travers
le soutien
de toutes les choses
et les gouvernements
de l'histoire
sont ses attributs
moraux parfaits.
Donc la nature
va révéler
la puissance
de Dieu
en certains niveaux
de sa bonté
etc.
mais c'est surtout
quand on commence
à considérer
comment Dieu
est en train
de se présenter
de manière personnelle
que nous voyons
la beauté.
Donc quel est
les plus grands commandements ?
Quelle est la conception
des vies
pour la gloire des dieux ?
C'est d'aimer
Dieu
sur toutes les choses
et les prochains
comme nous-mêmes.
Et donc
les commandements
ne peuvent pas
être arbitraires.
On n'est pas
qu'est sur la prérogative
du Dieu créateur
qui est les juges
qui exigent
de nous
qu'on l'adore.
Ça fait partie
de la nature
de l'amour
que l'adoration
soit quelque chose
de volontaire.
Et l'adoration
est tout simplement
une réponse
à la contemplation
de la gloire des dieux.
Quand on considère
le fait
que Dieu nous a créés
pour vivre
pour sa gloire
il est en train
de nous protéger
contre notre plus grand mal
l'idolâtrie
mais de promouvoir
notre plus grand bien
trouver notre satisfaction
dans la contemplation
et dans la réjouissance
d'une relation avec lui.
Car au centre
de cette création
qui était très belle
il y a eu
un être
qui a été créé
à l'image des dieux
et de toutes nos facultés
pour plus
que ce soit glorieux
de reproduire
plusieurs facettes
de l'œuvre des dieux
être au moins
un être noble
créatif
intelligent
on peut faire
des poèmes
de musique
etc.
Mais d'entre
toutes nos facultés
à l'image des dieux
celle qui est la plus élevée
c'est la capacité
de réjouir
d'une relation
proche avec dieux
et donc
heureusement
dieux nous a créés
pour sa gloire
car
comme dit Augustin
l'âme humaine
n'est jamais satisfaite
à moins qu'elle se retourne
vers dieux son créateur
et donc
dans ces mondes
qui est entouré
des empreintes
de la gloire
de Dieu
toutes ces empreintes
sont en train
de pointer
envers une relation
avec Dieu
pour qu'on se satisfasse
en Dieu
et en réponse
on vit une vie
pour sa gloire
donc car
Dieu
en tant qu'être
personnel
est glorieux
il veut révéler
surtout sa personne
relationnelle
envers nous
à travers la création
et donc
les dieux glorieux
personnels
est le fondement
de notre relation
donc heureusement
Dieu
est
le fondement
d'une vie
vécue
pour toute sa gloire
mais il y a
une deuxième vérité
qu'on doit considérer
et c'est
nous ne pourrons
jamais vivre
une vie
pour la gloire
de Dieu
à moins que Dieu
ne nous soit révélé
ou que Dieu
ne se révèle pas
à nous
sa gloire
de manière salvatrice
et ça c'est très important
donc dans ces textes
on a quelques
mises en question
qui pointent
envers notre incapacité
de connaître
Dieu
comme il fallait
et dans un certain sens
nous vivrons
pour la gloire
de Dieu
à la proportion
où nous connaissons
et réjouissons
de sa gloire
quand on parle
de la gloire
de Dieu
nous parlons
de sa beauté
et nous
en tant qu'être humain
à l'image de Dieu
on a plusieurs
facettes
ou facultés
de nos vies
qui ont des demandes
qui ne peuvent être
satisfaites qu'un Dieu
nous avons du plaisir
quand on regarde
un film
qui a beaucoup
d'intelligence
un peu cachée
et qu'on essaye
de découvrir les choses
dans l'appréciation
de l'intelligence
derrière les arts
on a
l'appréciation
de ce qui est beau
de ce qui est bon
de ce qui est juste
et toute cette demande
morale
ne peut qu'être
satisfaites
infiniment et pleinement
quand on contemple
la gloire de Dieu
la somme
de toutes ses vertus
l'éclat de sa gloire
les rayonnements
de sa majesté
mais c'est clair
c'est Dieu
pour plus
qui se révèle
à travers la nature
et d'autres moyens
il restera
pour toujours
incompréhensible
donc
nous serons
toujours capables
de contempler
des nouvelles mesures
de la gloire de Dieu
et nous devons vivre
proportionnellement
une vie pour sa gloire
à la mesure
où on prend plaisir
dans cette adoration
mais le problème
c'est que
c'est pas que
la limitation
en tant qu'être humain
finie
nous empêche
de contempler
davantage la gloire de Dieu
le problème c'est que
nous ne sommes pas
qui en train de contempler
très peu
de la gloire de Dieu
nous sommes constamment
en train de tourner
nos visages
contre la gloire de Dieu
et donc
le problème radical
de l'homme
c'est la corruption
du cœur
la corruption morale
et dans ce sens là
Calvin la décrit
avant tout
comme
idolâtrie
les cœurs humains
est une fabrique
d'idole
une usine
et comme nous sommes
en train de considérer
dans notre série
sur Galates
ce sont les œuvres
de la chair
Paul
dans la lettre au romain
il avait déjà traité
ça depuis le début
par définition
et par défaut
l'idolâtrie
est la racine
de tous les péchés
car attention
si Dieu nous a créés
pour vivre
pour sa gloire
la désobéissance
de n'importe quel commandement
c'est d'avoir mis
quelques autres choses
à la place des dieux
pour dicter
la manière
dont on doit vivre
!
c'est de mettre en question
la sagesse
ou la bonté
des dieux
lorsqu'il est en train
de nous commander
de vivre
d'une certaine manière
et donc
toutes les sortes
de transgressions
ont pour racine
l'idolâtrie
mais attention
n'est pas
qui est la racine
de tous les péchés
elle est
attention s'il vous plaît
l'opposé
l'antonyme
d'adoration
car la seule
réponse
appropriée
à la contemplation
d'un être
qui est totalement
aimable
c'est une vie
d'adoration pleine
vous êtes avec moi?
et donc
nous n'allons jamais
vivre
pour la gloire
des dieux
à moins que
dieux
manifeste
de manière
salvatrice
sa gloire
dans nos cœurs
car nos cœurs
sont corrompus
et il est en train
constamment
de mettre
d'autres choses
à la place
des dieux
donc
est-ce que nos cœurs
mettent à la place
des dieux
c'est de tourner
les visages
qui devraient être
fixés
sur la face
des dieux
et de nous diriger
vers sa mort
de
le lieu de considérer
cette relation
d'amour
avec celui
qui nous donne
toutes les choses
la source
de tous les biens
on est en train
de nous accrocher
aux dons
ou aux bénédictions
qu'il peut nous donner
et donc
selon les paramètres
bibliques
toutes les choses
peuvent devenir
résidables
nous pourrions penser
de manière
très
évidente
que Isaac
les fils d'Abraham
ont été mis
à l'épreuve
car Isaac
pourrait devenir
pour lui
ses fils
tant attendus
en idole
nous pouvons
penser
des plus parfaits
de la femme
samaritaine
qui était à la recherche
avec son cinquième
homme déjà
et à nouveau
cette chose
idéalisée
qui peut même
nous empêcher
d'avoir
un conjoint
réel
la réputation
professionnelle
par exemple
du créditeur
infidèle
qui a dit
une fois
qu'il a perdu
son emploi
il avait honte
de demander
aux autres
d'être accroché
à une réputation
passée
de revenir
en arrière
dans nos vies
les succès
professionnels
car ces choses
non seulement
supposent
donner signification
à nos vies
mais lorsqu'ils
nous les perdons
on imagine
que notre vie
ne peut plus
continuer
et c'est intéressant
de remarquer
dans l'histoire
que les hommes
des dieux
qui ont les plus
glorifié Dieu
dans leur vie
ce sont des hommes
qui ont dû laisser
en arrière
quelques idoles
en potentiel
donc Simon
les élotes
il a dû remettre
dans les bons ordres
la priorité
de sa cause politique
car par plusieurs
aujourd'hui
les causes politiques
prennent la place
des dieux
dans leur cœur
nous devons penser
à la position
qu'Ezaché
a dû
rénoncer
ou qu'il était
au moins
prédisposé
à rénoncer
pour pouvoir
suivre les Christ
mais attention
car même
les sacrifices
qu'on fait
pour les rois
des dieux
peuvent devenir
des idoles
pour nous
si nous les glorifions
dans ces choses
et donc
lorsque Pierre
a dit
Seigneur
nous avons
tout laissé
pour te suivre
le Christ
va exhorter
tout de suite
personne
n'a rénoncé
des choses
légitimement
pour me suivre
sans avoir
compris
qu'il avait
gagné déjà
le monde entier
avant
les détachements
de ces idoles
pour un vrai
chrétien
est précédé
par une manifestation
salvatrice
du Christ
dans leur cœur
mais c'est vrai
qu'à cause
des restes
de la chair
à plusieurs reprises
lorsqu'ils nous sommes
en train de mettre
trop d'importance
à des choses
qui peuvent nous empêcher
de glorifier Dieu
comme les confort
la protection
nous nous empêchons
aussi
de prendre
des risques
qui glorifient Dieu
comme les protestants
réformés ont pris
et de pouvoir
par là
constater
la fidélité
de Dieu
dans la réussite
de leur entreprise
pour la gloire
de Dieu
et donc
nous ne pouvons
être privés
de la gloire
de Dieu
qu'est par
l'idolâtrie
car
par défaut
!
est l'opposé
de la seule réponse
à la vraie connaissance
de Dieu
je vous explique
après ma conversion
une série d'études
qui était la fondation
de ma foi
c'était
la série
Darcy Sproul
la sainteté des dieux
et c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
dans les passages
qu'il va évoquer
la vision d'Esaïe
chapitre 6
que
Esaïe
a contemplé
une vision
salvatrice
qui Dieu l'a manifestée
dans ces cadres
Esaïe va contempler
Dieu
dans sa majesté
dans sa gloire
qui va remplir
une vision célestiale
du temple des dieux
et il y a
certains êtres
qui ont les privilèges
d'être davantage
proches
de la gloire des dieux
les anges
ces anges
ont trois pères d'elles
et les principaux
à considérer
ce sont
ces ailes
qui couvrent
leur visage
la gloire
de la majesté
de Dieu
si éclatante
que même
les anges
ne peuvent pas
contempler
directement
mais une réponse
évidente
à la gloire
de Dieu
la sainteté
éclate
devant leurs yeux
et la réponse
c'est
adoré
sans
elle éternelle
toute la terre
est remplie
de
sa gloire
et
Esaïe
a le privilège
de contempler
la majesté
de Dieu
c'est ça
qu'on traverse
quand on traverse
l'expérience
des conversions
comme a dit
Paquer
le ministère
du saint
esprit
c'est un ministère
de projection
des lumières
la première chose
et Calvin
il partageait
cette vision
car il disait
c'est impossible
de se connaître
soi-même
sans avant
connaître Dieu
car lorsqu'il nous
contemplant Dieu
dans la beauté
de sa gloire
de sa sainteté
immédiatement
cette lumière
qui est d'abord
projetée vers Dieu
Dieu devient
infiniment désirable
mais nous constatons
aussi que nous sommes
complètement indignes
de sa présence
et le saint esprit
lance la lumière
vers notre nature
à la lumière
des dieux
et de ce qui
Dieu attendait
de nous
et nous sommes
complètement couverts
des convictions
de notre pauvreté
spirituelle
désespérés
hommes qui nous sommes
qui peuvent nous
délivrer
de la pire
déprivation
de l'univers
être privés
de la gloire
de Dieu
et le saint esprit
ne nous laisse pas
abandonner
dans cette condition
il nous tourne
heureusement
vite
c'est l'expérience
de conversion
pour tous les vrais
chrétiens
indépendamment
du niveau
d'intensité
le saint esprit
nous fait contempler
les Christ
les médiateurs
parfaits
complètement
couverts
des convictions
des péchés
et désireux
de couvrir
un vide
qu'on ne peut
jamais combler
un Dieu
merveilleux
qui ne
ne pouvons jamais
être acceptés
dans sa présence
et un Christ
par la foi
nous devenons
complètement
acceptables
les mouvements
du texte
d'Esaïe
est intéressant
car
Jérémie
contemple
cette gloire
salvatrice
des dieux
et ensuite
il est consacré
à une vie
complètement dévouée
pour la gloire
des dieux
peu importe
ce qu'il va traverser
même si son ministère
n'aura pas
beaucoup de fruits
visibles
il va tout
endurer
fidèlement
car un jour
il a contemplé
la gloire
des dieux
et il n'a pas
pu s'empêcher
de vivre
désormais
pour sa gloire
lave
mes lèvres
mes voici
en vois-moi
peu importe
ce qui se passe
et quelle était
la fondation
de cette vie
Dieu
qui manifeste
de manière
salvatrice
sa gloire
à Esaïe
et donc
Calvin a mis
beaucoup d'emphase
sur ces premiers pas
qu'on doit donner
identifier dans nos cœurs
quels sont les idoles
qui occupent
la place des dieux
dans nos vies
qui nous empêchent
de vivre sa gloire
et pratiquer
non l'iconoclasme
sortir et casser
toutes les idoles
de l'église catholique
comme faisait
quelques radicaux
pendant la réforme
mais il parlait
d'un iconoclasme
spirituel
casser ces dieux-là
qui sont dans nos cœurs
mais en même temps
c'est cette compréhension
des calvins
par rapport
à l'œuvre salvatrice
qui est Dieu
qui peut opérer
rendait très clair
que nous n'aurons
jamais la capacité
d'enlever
ces idoles
de leur place
nous pouvons essayer
d'échanger
on enlève
un faux dieux
de nos cœurs
et vite notre vie
va se tourner
vers un autre idole
on va essayer
dans cette vie
par plusieurs bénédictions
parfois légitimes
chercher à combler
les vides
qui est ce qui est Dieu
qui peut combler
et donc
à moins que Dieu
lui-même
ne révèle
sa gloire
de manière salvatrice
dans nos cœurs
nous n'allons
jamais avoir
la capacité
de briser
nos idoles
et de remplacer
pour la vraie adoration
la bonne nouvelle
et la troisième vérité
pour nous
c'est que Dieu
nous a montré
sa gloire
de manière salvatrice
souprimement
dans l'avènement
du Seigneur Jésus Christ
c'est ça
les thèmes des romans
chapitres 10
et particulièrement
dans ces passages
car Dieu a tous livré
dans la désobéissance
afin d'avoir
pitié
de tous
l'emphase
de l'apôtre Paul ici
c'est
cette manière
dont
Dieu a révélé
la gloire
de sa miséricorde
de sa justice
la gloire
de sa gouvernance
de l'histoire
la gloire
du but
et du sens
de toute l'histoire
l'existence
et la création
de faire converger
toutes les choses
dans la pleine manifestation
du Christ
et donc
le contexte
il parle explicitement
de la manifestation
de la gloire
salvatrice
des dieux
à la croix
c'est une œuvre
attention
objective
qui a eu lieu
dans les temps
dans l'espace
qui a divisé l'histoire
c'est un fondement
solide
historique
sur lesquels
nous basons
notre foi
cela nous fait
réfléchir
le fait
que même
si Dieu
n'était
jamais
caché
dans la création
dans notre soutien
Dieu
se révèle
de manière
particulièrement
explicite
dans l'histoire
de l'humanité
car si
le péché
de la gloire
c'est l'homme
qui essaie
de se mettre
à la place
de Dieu
la gloire
salvatrice
de Dieu
se révèle
car Dieu
s'est mis
lui-même
dans la personne
de son fils
à la place
de nos idoles
à la croix
voici
l'iconoclasme
cosmique
l'image
exacte
de l'être
de Dieu
représentant
toutes nos
fausses
idoles
et étant
crucifié
à la croix
et au même temps
qu'il était
en train
d'expier
notre idolâtrie
car il a vécu
une vie
de dévotion
pleine
et parfaite
à Dieu
dans tous
les rôles
de sa vie
soumis
en tant qu'enfant
dans son rôle
familial
diligent
dans ses tâches
dans la société
dans son travail
et pouvant dire
mes paroles
ne sont pas
les paroles
que j'ai dit
mais les paroles
de mon père
en disant
que ta volonté
soit faite
et non la mienne
une riturge
c'est de faire
la volonté
de celui
qui m'a envoyé
son plaisir
sa passion
sa dévotion
était centré
sur Dieu seul
la gloire
de Dieu seul
donc il nous a manifesté
ce qui est
vivre pour la gloire
de Dieu
il a vécu
une vie
de dévotion
pleine
pour la gloire
de Dieu
mais étant
l'image exacte
de l'être
des dieux
il est exposé
comme l'être
le plus glorieux
donc il a expié
nos fautes
de la croix
l'équivalent
de la souffrance
à l'enfer
qu'on mériterait
souffrir
est retombé
sur Christ
car cet iconoclasme
visible
Christ crucifié
à la croix
n'est pas
la cause
physique
de la mort
de Jésus
la crucifixion
n'était pas
la cause
de la mort
du Christ
car
tous les données
scientifiques
historiques
montrent
que les personnes
pouvaient rester
jusqu'à 5 jours
voire plus
à la croix
il est mort
dans 3 heures
et la seule
explication
ce sont les choses
par rapport
auxquelles
lui Christ
lui-même
s'éplante
la croix
mon Dieu
pourquoi
m'as-tu abandonné
aucune parole
du Christ
qui n'était pas
liée
à sa relation
intime
avec Dieu
ces ténèbres
qui représentaient
les jugements
cosmiques
qui devraient retomber
sur nous
démontrent
que le Christ
est mort à la croix
car il était
en train de souffrir
de notre problème
spirituel
notre séparation
des dieux
nous priver
de la gloire
des dieux
notre rébellion
notre idolâtrie
et donc
Christ à la croix
est en train
de crucifier
en lui-même
et nous par la foi
en lui
comme Paul va nous dire
car ceux qui sont
Jésus-Christ
parce qu'il dit
au Galate
chapitre 5
ont crucifié
la chair
avec ses passions
et l'une des œuvres
de la chair
qu'il vient de lister
c'est l'idolâtrie
et donc c'est intéressant
à la croix
Dieu était en train
de commettre
cet iconoclasme
cosmique
pour détruire
tous nos faux idoles
mais pas que ça
il était en train
de mettre
en évidence
et de replacer
dans l'histoire
de l'humanité
du cosmos
de manière visible
explicite
l'opposé infini
de ce qui pourrait être
une gloire des dieux
cachée
c'est d'avoir
élevé sur ces bois
la manifestation
salvatrice
de sa gloire
à l'extrême
car même les anges
sont intéressés
ces mêmes anges
qui sont là
en train d'adorer
dans la vision des Haïts
ils sont particulièrement
intéressés
dans l'oeuvre du Christ
envers son peuple sauvé
pourquoi ?
car ils ont connu
une bonne mesure
de l'amour des dieux
de la grâce des dieux
mais ils n'ont pas connu
cette conception
des miséricordes
où Dieu va exercer
ou vivre
notre misère
à notre place
ils n'ont pas connu
une deuxième chance
une possibilité
d'avoir compris
la grâce des dieux
de manière
qui nous sommes enlevés
de la position
de mériter l'enfer
à la position
d'être traités
par Dieu lui-même
comme Christ
son fils bien-aimé
en qui Dieu a mis
toute son affection
donc la croix
est la manifestation
de la sagesse
de Dieu
qui a fait
que la justice
de Dieu
et l'amour
et la miséricorde
de Dieu
s'embrassent
car la justice
de Dieu
est manifestée
à l'extrême
lorsque pour nous sauver
il ne peut pas
épargner son propre
fils
mais l'amour
de Dieu
est aussi manifesté
à l'extrême
car pour nous sauver
il a supporté
il a souffert
la mort
de son propre fils
donc Dieu
devient inévitablement
l'objet suprême
d'adoration
dans les cœurs
donc croyant
lorsqu'il non seulement
nous parlons
de la croix du Christ
et nous étudions
bibliquement
historiquement
l'événement
de la croix du Christ
mais surtout
lorsqu'il est Saint-Esprit
vient à côté
de la proclamation
de Jésus
pour placarder
devant nos yeux
spirituels
Christ comme crucifié
c'est une expérience
qui doit avoir lieu
dans les cœurs
Paul l'a dit
lorsqu'il a plu
à celui
qui m'avait séparé
d'élévante et ma mère
de révéler son fils
en moi
c'est la seule guérison
et c'est la guérison
efficace
contre tous nos idoles
contempler
la gloire
salvatrice
de Dieu
révélé
en Jésus-Christ
et c'est à partir
de là
que nous allons
comprendre
que ça devient
impossible
et inévitable
de ne pas
vivre pour la gloire
de Dieu
une fois qu'on a
contemplé Christ
et qu'il est
entronisé
dans nos cœurs
nous pouvons
nous pouvons mettre
en question
par rapport
à la mesure
dans laquelle
on vit
pour la gloire
de Dieu
mais nous devons
mettre en question
l'authenticité
du salut
lorsque la personne
n'est pas nourrie
par la gloire
de Dieu
pour vivre
pour la gloire
de Dieu
dans une certaine mesure
quand on considère
la vie des
yugénaux
qui ont donné
leur vie
pour faire
promouvoir
l'évangile
quand on considère
toutes ces
qu'ils ont laissé
derrière
tous les idoles
qui pourraient
devenir des idoles
pour eux
comme par exemple
la majorité
d'entre eux
très bonne éducation
dégré
richesse
famille
c'était plutôt
et surtout
la noblesse
de la France
qui était là
représentée
ils ont tous perdu
ils sont partis
mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est que
tout comme
les yugénaux
et les premiers martyrs
de l'histoire
de l'église
ils ont pu
se détacher
de ces trésors
car ils ont contemplé
comme Paul a dit
il va présenter
son curriculum
Philippien III
il va démontrer
tout ce qui pour lui
était son importance
sa réputation
c'est bien
la manière
que vous vous présentez
aux autres
quand vous vous présentez
qu'est-ce que vous parlez
d'abord
votre famille
votre dégré
votre nationalité
Paul
serviteur
esclave du Christ
appelé
être apôtre
et pourquoi
car toutes les étoiles
comme dit
Hendrick V
toutes les étoiles
auxquelles on s'accroche
une fois que le soleil
s'élève
elles disparaissent
leur rayonnement
disparaissent
comme Lloyd Jones
qui avait une carrière
très prometteuse
en tant que médecin
même auxiliaire
de la reine d'Angleterre
et qu'une fois
qu'il a tout renoncé
il a dit
j'ai rien renoncé
je considère
comme le plus grand
privilège
qu'un être
qui m'en soit appelé
à s'engager
en ministère
sacré
donc elle était
la base
ou la fondation
c'est ce que
Thomas Chalmers
a présenté
comme la puissance
exclusive
d'un nouvel amour
la gloire du Christ
manifestée
devant nos yeux
et débordant
dans une vie
d'odoration
une vie vécue
pour sa gloire
et donc
la quatrième vérité
qu'il doit considérer
la dernière
c'est que
la gloire salvatrice
des dieux
en Jésus Christ
est un fondement
efficace
pour une vie vécue
pour sa gloire seule
et donc
nous avons
attention
nous avions
un problème radical
l'idolâtrie
en Jésus Christ
elle est guérie
mais efficacement
tous les chrétiens
peuvent aujourd'hui
sont habilités
aujourd'hui
même si nous n'allons
pas vivre
parfaitement
exclusivement
pour la gloire
des dieux
les restes
de la chair
seront là
en train de faire
appel à plusieurs
idolâtries
mais la réalité
c'est que nous
pouvons
déjà
progressivement
et efficacement
vivre pour la gloire
des dieux
et donc nous revenons
à ces passages
vers la fin
pour constater
à lui soit la gloire
pour toujours
non seulement
comme un constat
tout va glorifier
Dieu finalement
mais aussi
comme une exhortation
les chrétiens
doivent
intentionnellement
vivre
pour la gloire
des dieux
nous devons
aller nous coucher
et nous réveiller
en prenant en considération
cette tâche principale
celle qui devait être
notre plus grand plaisir
comment je peux plaire
Dieu aujourd'hui
avec mes pensées
avec mes paroles
avec mes services
comment peux-je
présenter mon corps
en réponse
à la révélation
glorieuse
de la sagesse
et des miséricordes
des dieux
comment je peux
présenter à Dieu
un culte raisonnable
en présentant mon corps
comme un sacrifice
vivant
de reconnaissance
à Dieu
pour glorifier son nom
et c'était ça
l'emphase
et la relation
entre la gloire
des dieux
du Christ
et une vie
complètement récule
pour sa gloire
la solution
c'est donc
de cultiver
cette contemplation
cette proximité
avec Jésus Christ
c'était de vivre
une vie intentionnelle
pour la gloire
des dieux
et il y a ici
dans ces passages
trois termes
ou quatre termes
qui nous montrent
de manière très
puissante
ce qui était
les emphases
des réformateurs
pour une vie
vécue pour la gloire
des dieux
la première
c'est celle
qui est présentée
ici par l'apôtre Paul
comme des lui
des lui
par lui
et pour lui
sont toutes choses
et donc des lui
c'est la reconnaissance
que tous les dons
toute l'existence
toute la maintenance
de nos vies
viennent
des dieux
donc ça donne
un sens
d'entendance
ça donne un sens
d'humilité
de reconnaissance
et ça nous porte
et portait surtout
les réformateurs
vers la contemplation
de tout l'univers
pour identifier
quels sont les motifs
d'une vie
qui peut être vécue
pour la gloire des dieux
donc en contemplant
la nature
on voit à nouveau
l'intelligence
la bonté
la beauté
et ça portait
les puritains
les réformateurs
à vivre en vie
pour la gloire des dieux
avec l'industrie
la diligence
la sensation
d'être rédévable
à dieux
les manques d'orgueil
par rapport
à nos grandes oeuvres
car c'est dès lui
qu'il vient
toutes les choses
c'est la notion
qu'on peut parler
des vocations aussi
cette vocation
qu'on a
ou les plusieurs
vocations qu'on a
soit au travail
donc n'importe quel rôle
de la vie
l'emphase aussi
du fait que
toutes les choses
sont déluées
c'est-à-dire
il n'y a pas
un seul métier
qui ne soit pas
tous les métiers
légitimes bien sûr
qui ne soient pas
plaisantes
ou plaisibles à Dieu
donc c'est l'emphase
qu'ils ont mis
même
celui qui est en train
d'enlever
les laires
d'une vache
peut les faire
pour la gloire des dieux
avoir la sensation
peu importe
quelle soit
ma position
aujourd'hui
mon travail
ce n'est pas
le travail
de pasteur
qui sera plus important
que le travail
de celui
qui est en train
de faire
pour Dieu
devant les yeux
des dieux
comme celui
qui nous a donné
les dons
je vais faire
fidèlement
ce que Dieu
a mis dans ma vie
aujourd'hui
par sa providence
de faire
faire tout
pour la gloire
des dieux
donc c'était
cette notion
que tout
venait des dieux
et on devrait
suivre ces empreintes
de voir comment
Dieu fait les choses
et reproduire
et les puritans
qui étaient la génération
la prochaine génération
ils ont fait ça
de manière très diligente
ils sont allés
partout dans la bible
pour identifier
quel était leur rôle
en tant qu'père
en tant qu'mère
en tant qu'enfant
en tant que travailleur
et de chercher
donc à vivre
pour la gloire
des dieux
selon la bible
en toutes les aires
de la vie
ça parle
non seulement
de la manière
excellente
dont on doit faire
tous ses rôles
mais aussi
d'identifier
une hiérarchie
des priorités
pour ne pas sacrifier
les temps de famille
des enfants
pour l'idole
de travailler
avec l'excellence
pour la gloire
des dieux
mais il y a aussi
cet autre terme
qui démontre aussi
d'autres emphases
des réformateurs
qui c'est
c'est
délui
et c'est
pour lui
et c'était
aussi cette
conscience
intentionnelle
d'avoir
reçu
des dieux
les privilèges
sachant nous tous
qu'on était tous
serrés
dans la désobéissance
on a désormais
la possibilité
non seulement
d'accéder
à la présence
des dieux
mais de plaire
dieux
l'emphase
des puritains
sur la conception
d'avoir été
séparés
absolument
de la présence
des dieux
privés
de la gloire
des dieux
et de maintenant
pouvoir
non seulement accéder
à la présence
des dieux
mais plaire
dieux
d'écouter
nous aussi
ce que dieu a dit
à jésus christ
voici mon fils
bien aimé
en qui j'ai mis
toute mon affection
sur cette notion
des coran de la présence
des coran
des hauts
de vivre
devant la présence
des dieux
c'était
déchercher
à plaire
dieux
par toutes
les aires
de nos vies
j'ai la tentation
de dire
en ignorant
ceux qui sont devant nous
ne méritent pas
notre service
mais c'est mieux
que ça
c'est de voir
les potentiels
d'être l'image
des dieux
qui toutes les personnes
ont malgré la manière
dont ils sont en train
de se présenter
devant nous aujourd'hui
et de servir
christ
chez les autres
car même
les situations
les plus difficiles
comme l'apôtre Paul
nous dit
pour un serviteur
servez vos maîtres
un esclave
comme si vous étiez
en train de servir
christ lui-même
c'est la manière
dont christ
nous a servi
et donc nous devons
vivre
en vie
pour la gloire
des dieux
dans tous nos rôles
envers nos parents
envers la société
comme ceux
qui sont en train
de faire
toutes les choses
pour plaire
l'audience
d'un salon
l'audience des dieux
je suis en train
de faire toutes les choses
pour la gloire des dieux
et c'est comme ça
par exemple
que les puritans
étaient découverts
quand ils étaient
sous persécution
ils savaient
qu'il s'agissait
d'un puritant
lorsqu'ils regardaient
combien ils étaient
en train de polir
dans une usine
des chaises
les parties
que personne
n'allait regarder
sauf Dieu
les enfants
quand ils sont en train
de ranger leur chambre
ils devraient penser
pas aux places
où papa et moi
ne vont pas regarder
mais Dieu
est en train de voir
toutes les choses
ça a marqué
à leur service
dans tous les sens
dans l'industrie aussi
voilà pourquoi
les huguenots
sous les disciples
poula des calvins
ont enrichi
plusieurs nations
vers lesquelles
ils se sont fuis
et combien la France
a été appauvrie
après les départs
des huguenots
toutes les choses
pour la gloire des dieux
comme pour Achare
l'habitude de dire
pourquoi Dieu
il fait
la fleur la plus belle
et la place
au milieu
du forêt
le plus obscur
et caché
où personne
ne peut les voir
et la réponse
c'est car Dieu
les voit
ça donne du sens
à toutes nos bonnes
œuvres faites
de manière invisible
car notre Dieu
qui va en sécré
va nous récompenser
et défaire
toutes les choses
pour Christ
chez les autres
car lorsque vous avez
donné un verre d'eau
à l'un de ces petits
mes frères
vous m'avez donné
à moi-même
vivre devant
la gloire des dieux
vivre pour
le troisième terme
qui est là
qui est très riche aussi
c'est non seulement
pour lui
et de lui
mais c'est aussi
par lui
ça c'est tout simplement
les plus beaux
les plus glorieux
et pourquoi ?
car comme je vous ai dit
au début
Dieu est en train
de révéler
non seulement
ses capacités
son intelligence
sa beauté
etc
il est en train
de se montrer
à travers l'univers
pour promouvoir
la relation
la personne
et l'essence
des privilèges
qu'avaient les réformateurs
de savoir
qu'ils étaient
non seulement
en train de servir
Christ chez les autres
mais ils étaient
en train de devenir
des petits Christ
pour les autres
l'emphase
sur l'intégrité
au travail
n'est pas cacher
mon identité
chrétienne au travail
car le mieux
que je peux donner
à mon entourage
c'est Christ
mon identité
ne peut jamais
être séparée
de l'identité
du Christ
une foi
qui ne peut pas
être vécue
publiquement
n'est pas une foi
c'est dit
l'idolâtrie
voilà pourquoi
Calvin a rompu
avec un mouvement
qui était ici
présent
en France
le début de la réforme
qui était un peu
encore à long terme
de l'église catholique
mais qui a fini
pour être supprimé
par les systèmes
les besoins
dérompent
Roy Jones
il va remarquer
que ce qui faisait
des puritains
les vrais puritains
par esprit
c'était les contacts
avec l'enfance
des Calvin
qu'ils ont perçus
qu'il fallait
séparer
pour assumer
une adoration
publique
qui plaît Dieu
quels étaient
les commandements
principaux
des dix commandements
tels que Dieu
les a révélés
au Sinaï
dix commandements
et un qui a été
choisi pour être
les symboles
et qui était aussi
la raison
pour laquelle
Dieu a eu
cette dispute
avec Pharaon
laisser mon peuple
aller pour
m'adorer
pour m'adorer
c'est les droits
à l'adoration
les droits
les plus fondamentaux
des l'être humain
les droits des hommes
!
les droits
à l'adoration
et donc Dieu
va révéler sa gloire
au Sinaï
et le peuple
va être appelé
à vivre
en vie
pour sa gloire
ensuite
et donc c'est important
de remarquer
les mieux
c'est de savoir
qu'on est en train
de vivre
par lui
car il est en train
de se révéler
à travers nous
et c'est cette conviction
que nous voyons
par exemple
en acte
chapitre 11
verset 26
pour la première fois
les chrétiens
les disciples
ont reçu
les noms
des chrétiens
d'agir
d'une manière
tellement similaire
à Christ
pour plaire
Christ
que nous sommes
pris par
petit Christ
mon pasteur
une fois
dans une nuit
froide
à Rio
il a vu
qu'il y avait
des enfants
qui n'avaient
pas
des manteaux
et il les a
donné les siens
et il a
continué
son chemin
ils les ont appelé
à nouveau
il a dit
seigneur
est-ce que
tu es un ange
ils ne pouvaient pas
croire en fait
quelques petites actions
qui peuvent faire
que nous soyons
confondus
par des petits
Christ
par des anges
comme c'était
le cas de l'apôtre
Paul
chez les Galates
vous m'avez reçu
comme un ange
comme Christ
lui-même
donc c'était
cette conscience
que je suis ici
pour être
le représentant
du Christ
et si je suis ici
pour être
le représentant
du Christ
j'ai le privilège
de présenter
Christ aux personnes
celles de la terre
lumière du monde
et plus que ça
comment pouvons-nous
présenter les Christ
de manière la plus
intentionnelle
c'est ça qui a fait
ces hommes mourir
c'est de proclamer
les Christ
publiquement
c'est d'évangéliser
les personnes
il n'y a aucune
manière de présenter
les Christ
de manière plus explicite
qui est de parler
la croix
et l'apôtre Paul
nous dit
qu'ils nous sommes
des ambassadeurs
pour Christ
des représentants
du Christ
comme si Dieu
exhortait par nous
en appelant
les personnes
vous prenez conscience
du fait
que Dieu
est en train
de se manifester
par nous
par son Saint-Esprit
par l'Esprit
du Christ
et lorsque Jésus
a promis
allez
faites des disciples
de toutes les nations
et j'essaierai
avec vous
pour tous les jours
jusqu'à la fin des temps
comment nous allons
ressentir
cette présence
fraîche
du Christ
cette compagnie
avec nous
c'est surtout
si nous sommes engagés
à la présentation
de l'évangile
car là
Christ est en train
de se manifester
aux personnes
à travers nos vies
par la proclamation
de l'évangile
et donc ces hommes
ont vécu
pour la gloire
de Dieu
avec la conscience
verset 36
la dernière déclaration
a su
à lui
sa la gloire
pour toujours
cette expression
est très importante
ils ont compris
que même s'ils sont
mortes
comme Paul
la mort
représentera pour eux
les sommets
de leur réjouissance
spirituelle
car ils seront
avec Christ
donc ces hommes
ils ont eu
des emprises
sur les choses
de ces mondes
de manière
très lâche
ils touchaient
les choses
légèrement
les bénédictions
temporelles
pour eux
les dégrés
les conforts
la sécurité
de ne pas perdre
mon emploi
qu'importe
comme dit le terre
dans
les remparts
qu'il y a notre vie
si on doit perdre
la famille
bien
plaisir
la vie même
son royaume
est éternel
nous devons faire
les mieux
que nous pouvons faire
dans cette génération
nous devons vivre
pour la gloire
des dieux
au maximum
qu'on puisse
dans cette génération
mais si notre vie
est coupée
nous sommes immédiatement
lancés dans la réjouissance
pleine de la gloire
des dieux
et c'est pour ça
que ces hommes
ont pu laisser
ces témoignages
cette nouée
des témoins
et c'est par leur exemple
et par ces
emphases bibliques
qu'on doit
faire
toutes les aires
de nos vies
enterrant
en missionnaire
afin de représenter
les Christ
pour les autres
afin de servir
les Christ
chez les autres
afin de proclamer
les Christ
et d'expérimenter
par là
la présence
du Christ
pendant que nous partageons
son glorieux évangile
car c'est de lui
c'est par lui
et pour lui
qui sont toutes les choses
à lui soit la gloire
pour toujours
Amen